have you ever built a gothic or baroque
spire or tower but it's liking that
sense of style that touch of refinements
right so here's how i turn my shitty
spires into witty spires first I like to
go to mobys glass house and frameworks
and get a 4h post from the middle of
that SATs here we go and I like to make
it this color of brown especially in
this case since it fits with the color
of the building but it really all
depends on whatever your taste is and
just place it onto the spire like that
and that is pretty much good to go now
this may look very ugly but the next
thing I always like to do is to get a
sphere from Main Street 5 from shy guy
and get that really dark one and make
sure it has that golden dark yellow
color and just put it onto the middle of
that post like that and then it should
already start looking more like some
very stereotypical Church post with
decorations and golden Spears on them
and the next thing you want to do is you
want to go to pat's after links that I
go into the wall section and you want to
find the pieces called peak and it
should be somewhere in the middle of the
set there we go and the first one I
always like to get is this one and place
it right on top of that little post that
you have right there but you can also
just place it in the middle of that and
another thing which I like to get is
this third peak and you can place that
one on top of the existing one just to
make that look a bit more fancy and then
you have your little decoration now
obviously this is use the base of what
you can do with this you can also take
the second peak and put it on there just
to provide a little bit more decoration
you can also lower the post and make
sure the ball the golden ball is lower
or use different elements i also really
like to get em fences whatever small
post to decorations you can get in to
make these things but generally I find
that these things make us buyers look a
lot better it's a very small easy and
not time-consuming thing to do but it
really helps to make buildings look more
inviting in general for an example and
showcase of where I've used these things
this is a Cathedral where i'll fuse the
golden balls and little peak pieces to
decorate the spires a bit but I even use
these little pieces to decorate the dome
and this tower on the side as well and
they can even work for a little and
building so really try these little
peeks out because they are really
amazing and see where ever you can use
them and that's it for this small
tutorial and thank you for watching and
I hope to see you another time